haha hey hair what's going on with you
my hair looks like it got done because I
did it myself because I do and then I
tried them on myself and it's because
I'm a girl the proportions here look a
little bit off to me that's better
hi guys I'm back it's Saturday right now
currently it's Saturday but if you're
watching this later then it's not
Saturday anymore for you
um that's sad I like Saturdays and
that's why I'm thinking of possibly
doing something get out here little Carl
go back with your friends I'm thinking
about starting something called Saturday
sessions here on this channel what do
you think about that I just post a very
simple video that just lets me tell you
a story about something that happened to
me during the week do you think that'd
be cool I think it'd be cool maybe so
here's something that happened to me
this week I was on a bus where I this
might be hard to explain but where I
live the bus route ends on one side of
the street and then the bus drives
around the traffic circle and then the
starts on the other side of the street I
see the bus coming to the end of its
line and so I run because I know that
bus is gonna start up again at the other
end of the line and it gets there before
me and it stops and it usually stops for
a few minutes at start anyway so I don't
know why I always run I'm always worried
that it's gonna be a real [ __ ] bus
driver and he's gonna stop for half a
second and then pull out really quickly
and not just be running in the
background like this because I always
abroad with my arms above my head I get
on the bus and the bus drivers eating
some kind of stew and he goes you want
some and I don't even share food with
friends at restaurants so I was like
nothing sets okay I'm cool he's like
okay I said how tall
and I said um five nine and a half how
tall are you
they said oh five eleven I said oh well
Thomas really runs my family my mom's
five ten he's like oh that's tall you
know you're gonna date the athletes and
that's like oh yeah no probably not
I'm not really into athletes when you
date the athletes you gotta get a good
lawyer she got a great lawyer um who got
a great lawyer oh she got a great lawyer
now he's still bad at golf Oh
Elin Elin got a great lawyer yeah yeah
she seven lawyers [ __ ] seven lawyers wow
that's a lot of lawyers to have
meanwhile people are filling in on the
bus I was like I didn't even really like
off ya know when you date the athlete
you have to get a good lawyer and I'm
not doing a good accent I think he was
um he wasn't Jamaican he wasn't
Dominican maybe I don't know exactly but
he had an accent that sounded different
than what I'm doing right now I'm just
yelling and and yelling and so then the
bus started up along its route and we
didn't talk at all and my bus ride was
only like three minutes maybe and then I
pushed the button for my stop and I got
off and I just gave him a little like
this and you could see in the rearview
mirror
good night lady and then I got off the
bus I might never see that man again but
he has given me great advice that was so
anticlimactic that ending I think I'm I
like telling stories but I haven't got
the format down completely because I
don't know how to end them in a way that
makes it pay off that you've been
listening for so long so let me know
what you think about Saturday sessions
when I was in high
well Saturday sessions were the tension
that you've got if you did something bad
you have to come in for a Saturday
session so don't want this to feel like
at school I don't want it to feel like
you've done something bad I just
wouldn't feel like oh it's Saturday
morning or no I won't be in the morning
cool it'll probably be in the afternoon
think about it I'll think about it in
the meantime I'm gonna watch some more
hair and makeup tutorials mmm beauty